herzlich willkommen zur folge 194 dass
er zeit einspruch podcast der
wöchentlichen podcast der faz für recht
justiz und politik heute am 26 januar
2022 ein sehr trüber tag und am mikrofon
begrüßen sie corinna budras und
verlor 19
heute haben wir wieder mit dem alten
intro
gestartet in der letzten woche hatten
wir uns ja bei der hinreißenden kollegin
sarah tacke direkt aus dem zdf heute
journal hier bedient kann natürlich auch
entsprechend gut an schöne grüße nochmal
nach mainz aber im moment sind wir jetzt
noch sehr konservativ wieder unterwegs
was das intro jedenfalls angeht liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen da draußen wenn
ihr uns mehr schön
genau da können wir jetzt in der tat
einen kleinen wettbewerb ausschreiben
apropos wettbewerb ausschreiben
wir haben kurzfristig noch referendars
kapazitäten frei sagt unser justiziariat
hier bei der faz
wirklich hinreißenden kollegen und wir
bilden eben auch aus und suchen immer
mal wieder
referendarinnen und referendare und
jetzt ist sehr kurzfristig was frei
geworden von april bis juli 2022 und da
können sich interessierte junge und
ältere bewerber und bewerberinnen
ja keine altersdiskriminierung hier bei
uns melden ich sah am besten mal noch
die e mail auch da kann man also nicht
nur mit kritik oder weitergehenden
vorschlägen sich melden sondern auch mit
solchen dingen das wäre ein spruch
podcast
faz.de
und wo wir schon beim bewerben sind kann
ich auch gleich sagen dass der faz
einspruch also das magazin an dem wir ja
auch eng und innig hängen eine
studentische aushilfe sucht die
regelmäßig ein mal die woche die inhalte
der faz
für faz einspruch aufbereitet so und da
können sie natürlich studenten aus ganz
deutschland bewerben gerne auch aus dem
rhein-main-gebiet damit man auch einen
kleinen anschluss an die redaktion
bekommt und die stellenausschreibung
findet sich und der
www.kath.net schrägstrich bewerber und
das werde ich auch noch mal in die show
notes tun so jetzt haben wir hanna
inhalte bald unsere personal engpässe
überwunden mit ihrer hilfe mit eurer
hilfe und jetzt können wir zu den themen
an diesem mittwoch findet ihr die erste
orientierungs debatte im bundestag statt
zum thema impfpflicht allgemeine
impfpflicht oder auch alters bezogen wie
immer man das dann am ende aus gestalten
möchte und auch an uns geht das thema
nicht spurlos vorbei wir schauen uns mal
an wie die debatte in den vereinigten
staaten gelaufen ist da wurde die erste
versuch eine allgemeine impfpflicht der
gerade vom supreme court abgeräumt und
dazu hole ich mich gleich mal meinen
förderung kollegen patrick bahners
wieder ins studio so ihr habt aber noch
ein zweites wunderschönes thema was
glaubst du doch nicht verschweigen ja da
wären wir noch einen kleinen schlenker
zu machen und zwar wird gerade die
bibliothek von der legendären supreme
court richterin ruth bader ginsburg
versteigert und auch darüber plaudern
wir was die so alles in ihrer bibliothek
hatte so und dann kommen wir zum
bundesverwaltungsgericht napier das
bundesverwaltungsgericht hat einen
beschluss der stadt münchen quasi
aufgehoben für rechtswidrig erklärt mit
dem die stadt münchen untersagen wollte
das dort unter anderem die bds bewegung
diskutieren kann da gab es ein paar
lustige wollten in münchen und es gab
auch würde ich sagen bundesweit den
versuch dieses urteil so ein bisschen in
seiner bedeutung zu reduzieren wir
finden es aber durchaus bedeutsam und
haben es euch mal mitgebracht vielleicht
erklärst du noch mal ganz kurz was die
bds bewegung ist die hat sich glaube ich
noch nicht so wahnsinnig durchgesetzt
also bds steht für boykott bei west ment
und sanctions da handelt es sich um eine
bewegung die sich selbst als
repräsentantinnen der palästinensischen
zivilgesellschaft bestimmt bezeichnet
und diese für die menschenrechte der
palästinenser einsetzen möchte zwar
gewaltfrei aber mit durchaus sehr sehr
scharfen mitteln nämlich mit dem aufruhr
eben zum boykott gegen israel in israel
nicht zu investieren und israelische
waren sport und kulturveranstaltungen zu
boykottieren daher wird diese bewegung
durchaus als antisemitisch wahrgenommen
bundesweit auch wenn sie selbst explizit
nicht als antisemit antisemitisch gelten
möchte genau also all das wird noch mal
hier eine rolle spielen und dann widmen
wir uns auch wieder den täglichen
höchsten der korona neuinfektion ein
ziemlich unerfreuliches thema da
offenbaren sich ja immer mehr defizite
unserer test strategien die können wir
zwar hier nicht umfassend beschreiben
aber wir können auf eine interessante
vergaberechtliche komponente man
hinweisen die immerhin dazu führt dass
hier in der hauptstadt die leute
mitunter mal fünf stunden nun für so ein
test für sohn pcr tests anstehen müssen
also in deren haut möchte ich nicht
stecken du hast ja mal wieder so ein
berlin klassiker dabei darauf ja genau
und gleich spreche ich noch mit meinem
kollegen reinhard müller der hat uns
einen kuriosen fall mitgebracht nämlich
den fall eines tschechischen millionärs
der hier auf der autobahn mit seinem
bugatti lange brettert ist mit tempo 417
und wir schauen uns jetzt mal an ob das
strafrechtliche konsequenzen hat so und
dann pia präsentierst du uns noch das
gerechte urteil der woche
[Musik]
kommen wir jetzt also erstmal zum
heiklen thema im pflicht in deutschland
beginnt die debatte erst ich habe schon
gerade erwähnt in anderen ländern ist
sie bereits im vollen gange wir wollen
deshalb jetzt einmal für unsere
orientierung in die vereinigten staaten
blicken und dazu habe ich mir immer
wieder meinen kollegen patrick bahners
ins studio geholt er ist redakteur im
feld und intimer kenner der
rechtsprechung des supreme court herr
bahners schön dass ich mal wieder hier
sind ich freue mich auch gut um das
ergebnis einmal vorweg zu nehmen also
der supreme court hatte dem
amerikanischen präsidenten joe biden
einen ordentlichen strich durch die
rechnung gemacht vielleicht klären wir
mal vorneweg wie sah die impfpflicht
eigentlich in amerika aus beim supreme
courts in zwei fälle gelandet die dann
auch unterschiedlich entschieden wurden
aber sie haben schon recht dass in dem
fall der die weitaus umfassendere
impfpflicht
betraf eben das gericht den präsidenten
in die parade gefahren ist und gesagt
hat das war nicht in ordnung dass dort
die für arbeitsschutz zuständige behörde
eine regelung erlassen hatte wonach in
allen unternehmen in den vereinigten
staaten mit mehr als 100 beschäftigten
eine impfpflicht herrscht respektive
wenn wenn die beschäftigten nicht sich
impfen lassen müssen sie sich halt
testen lassen und dieses das wurde eben
vom supreme court verworfen gebilligt
hat der supreme court eine auf die auf
das gesundheitssystem auf eine andere
rechtsgrundlage gestützte impfpflicht
eben für die angestellten in
krankenhäusern pflegeheimen so weiter
ich bin übrigens bei der amerikanischen
debatte hoch interessant dass die
adrette da die ausflucht über den test
tatsächlich funktionierte also
tatsächlich leuten die sich vehement
verweigern ist nicht ganz die tür
zugeschlagen sondern der test ist da
immer noch eine option und zwar übrigens
nur einmal die woche das fand ich auch
an das jahr klingen bis in halbherzig
letztendlich na ja es klingt halbherzig
oder
entgegenkommend und ja umso
dass das dann der mehrheit der supreme
court richter nicht genügt hat also in
dem eben in diesem urteil über die
impfpflicht für alle unternehmen da gab
es eine klare mehrheit von 623 stimmen
wo alle sogenannten konservativen
richter also auch der
gerichtsvorsitzende john roberts eben
der meinung waren das geht nicht und die
drei liberalen richter die eine
abweichende meinung zu protokoll gegeben
haben die weißen gerade darauf hin und
sagen eben dass die bedenken also auch
medizinische bedenken auch religiöse
bedenken die in amerika besonders ernst
genommen werden dass das alles
eigentlich in dieser verordnung der
arbeitsschutzbehörde berücksichtigt war
so dass die die center sogar schreiben
es ist als ihrer sicht streng genommen
sogar falsch von einer impfpflicht
zwischen rächen weil es eigentlich so
eine regelung mit einer gabelung ist ein
entweder impfung oder eben dieser
wöchentliche test also auch da schon hat
man eigentlich einen vermittelnden weg
gewählt auch übrigens einen der weit
entgegenkommen da ist als das was hier
gerade in deutschland debattiert wird da
kommen wir gleich noch zu ich fand auch
interessant in den vereinigten staaten
im von dem supreme court spielten sehr
stark formalistische gründe eine rolle
also es ging gerade gegen den strich
dass das eine behörde eine bundesbehörde
ist für arbeitsschutz die das geregelt
hat ne ja ja ja da waren eben auch es
waren ja auch eine ganze reihe von
bundesstaaten ich glaube sogar mehr als
die hälfte der bundesstaaten hatte eben
mit föderalistischen argumenten
protestiert gegen diese regelung und man
sieht dann eben auch dass das natürlich
ein solches urteil auch so ernst der
gegenstand ist natürlich von einem
kontinuierlich tagenden arbeitenden das
recht fortentwickelten gericht dann auch
dazu genutzt wird fragen zu diskutieren
und nochmal die unterschiedlichen
standpunkte 1 zu schaffen
die sozusagen immer anliegen auch jetzt
außerhalb so einer notlage die ja von
niemandem bestritten wird aber es
verwundert einen dann natürlich
eigentlich nicht dass die das eben diese
konservativen richter auch die
gelegenheit nutzen noch einmal ihren
standpunkt eben klar klar zu machen man
muss eben sehr genau dem staat und der
bürokratie auf die auf die finger gucken
und sozusagen ermächtigungen dürfen
nicht endlos gedehnt werden wenn also
eine behörde oder auch auf der
verfassungsebene
wenn eben der bund oder der kongress
prinzipiell ermächtigt ist etwas zu tun
heißt es nicht nur weil der gegenstand
unglaublich wichtig ist das dann
irgendwie alles alles möglich ist also
da da da streiten sich dann eigentlich
die beiden seiten im gericht dann über
ja eben nur formale fragen oder eben
fragen eigentlich auch der der mechanik
kann man vielleicht sagen auch der start
der staatsorganisation und aus dem aus
der perspektive des jähnigen der dann
denkt er ist persönlich getroffen er hat
vielleicht tatsächlich angst an seinen
arbeitsplatz zu gehen weil weil eben der
kollegen sich nicht impfen ankam impfen
lassen wird das dann bitter auch in dem
sondervotum wird das dann gerückt und
wird wird gesagt das ist eben jetzt hier
dieser diesen dieser dieser notstand da
muss man doch ins ins auge sehen aber
natürlich das würden wir denke ich auch
dann doch grundsätzlich erwarten müssen
die müssen die eben die gerichte auch
ihre abstrakten formalen und auch immer
auf das allgemeine hier also auf diese
fragen der arbeitsteilung sozusagen im
staatsaufbau gerichteten fragen müssen
sie natürlich auch im augen halten und
es interessante amerikanische fall war
ja dass das etwas wahr was jetzt so
beiden quasi angeordnet hat über diese
über das vehikel der behörde das heißt
der kongress das parlament ist gar nicht
involviert gewesen wahrscheinlich auch
wenn man das ich hätte durchsetzt ja
genau richtig und das ist dann auch ein
argument
eben der der mehrheit dafür dass sie das
dass sie sagen dass es fehlte eben die
die die legitimität dass sie sagen es
eigentlich hätte eben da gibt es gibt es
eben im amerikanischen verfassungsrecht
dann auch so eine analogie zu dieser
wesentlichkeit theorie diversen
deutschen verfassungsrecht kennen
wesentliche entscheidungen soll der
gesetzen lieber treffen genauso wird
daneben argumentiert und es wird darauf
hingewiesen von der von der mehrheit das
ist im senat eine abstimmung gab es
sogar eine mehrheit eben genau diese
impfpflicht also diese allgemeine
impfpflicht für für unternehmen an der
bestimmten größe passt ja was ja dann
große teile überhaupt der arbeitenden
bevölkerung der usa sind also je nach
art millionen könnte man die hafenstädte
man ja also genau also es ist eben ja
dass da liegt irgendwie da liegt ja dann
die frage schon auf der hand ist das
jetzt wirklich noch eine eine regelung
die die die arbeitende bevölkerung in
ihrer eigenschaft als arbeiter und
angestellte betrifft oder ist es nicht
ein umweg um eben für die fackel für die
gesamte bevölkerung
solche maßnahmen zu treffen und in der
tat eben es gab eine abstimmung im senat
und da war sogar eine mehrheit also
obwohl ja die demokraten also die partei
von präsident beiden ja mit der
vizepräsidentin diese ganz knappe
absolute mehrheit haben diese abstimmung
ging aber eben sogar gegen die
impfpflicht auch genau also da kann man
im grunde mal kurz zusammenfassen und
also politisch hat es nicht geklappt
also auf über parteiübergreifend hat man
das nicht hingekriegt in den vereinigten
staaten
unter hat das ist deswegen diesen weg
gegangen und das ist jetzt
verknallt am supreme court gescheitert
wollen wir mal hier jetzt nach
deutschland gucken vielleicht mal
vorneweg mich würde ihre meinung
interessieren wie finden sie denn das
verfahren jetzt generell was wir hier
haben also sehr ungewöhnlich ist ja das
ist kein regierungsentwurf gibt auch
eine klare entscheidung das nicht zu tun
sondern das über so genannte
gruppenanträge zu machen also jetzt
finden sich gerade drei gruppen haben
sich schon gefunden also herr kubicki
ist natürlich vorgeprescht der
fdp-politiker der ja schon sehr vehement
gesagt hatte es der gegend also der
antrag ganz klar lautet keine künftig
dann haben wir eine variante die auch
getragen wird von 1 3 ampel parteien um
den rechtspolitiker der krise steffen
und auch von der fdp ist frau
strack-zimmermann dabei und die sagen im
pflicht ab 18 und dann haben wir noch so
ein antrags also ein
verfahren das darauf zielt eine zwangs
beratung sozusagen von zu scheiden wie
finden sie denn generell vielleicht
geworfen das noch und die halbe sprechen
wie finden sie das verfahren generell
also grundsätzlich würde ich erst mal
sagen dass das das spricht jetzt ja auch
dafür dass es initiative und kreativität
im bundestag selber gibt wenn man dann
sich auch erinnert das ja viel
kritisiert worden ist ja sagen die
parlamente nicht gefragt worden dann ist
auch gesagt wurden ja die parlamente
müssen ja auch nicht ungefragt werden
die können ja von sich selbst auch abgas
werden dann ist das ist das ja zunächst
mal etwas etwas positives dass die sich
sozusagen selber sortieren und nach nach
sachlichen gesichtspunkten dann diese
alternativen ausformulieren und wenn man
es im vergleich jetzt noch mal ganz kurz
sieht eben mit den usa könnte man ja
vielleicht auch sagen eben man sieht ja
bei beiden in dieser unglaublich hoch
aufgeheizten polarisierten stimmung in
den usa ist ja alles was was die
regierung vorschlägt stößt ja fast
automatisch dort eben auf auf eine art
von opposition und die dann wegen der
starken position auch einer minderheit
insbesondere im senat kaum durchzusetzen
ist und hier in deutschland ist das ist
das eben zum glück haben wir nicht haben
wir ihn noch nicht diese ganz ganz
starke polarisierung aber natürlich ist
es auch so wenn wenn eine regierung sich
eine sache zu eigen macht dann wäre
eigentlich das normale dass die
opposition erstmal sich zweifelnd auf
die gegenseite stellt und und vielleicht
in vidic gegen gründe auf den tisch legt
etc und in dem eben hier der weg über
den bundestag gegangen wird
vermeidet man sozusagen entkoppelt man
eben diese frage was ist da eigentlich
sachlich richtig von der frage was dient
nun den vorteil dem prestige jetzt
gerade hier dieser neu startenden
bundesregierung so weit kann ich auch
noch finde ich es auch so zu sagen
eigentlich interessant und kann man das
mit gewissen optimismus verfolgen was
ich persönlich eher problematisch finde
ist dann diese analogie die hergestellt
wird mit den mit den mit den ethischen
fragen mit diesen ethischen grenzfragen
die ähnlich auch ohne den sogenannten
fraktionszwang in diesen sogenannten
freigegebenen abstimmung mit gruppen
anträgen in den vergangenen jahren
behandelt worden sind also sterbehilfe
abtreibung und so weiter da habe ich ein
bisschen die befürchtung dass da allein
schon das gewählte verfahren
dann eine sicht suggeriert dass man es
eben bei dieser impfpflicht frage
tatsächlich um eine so gravierende
ethisch möglicherweise auch in apulien
führende und politisch mit gesetzgebung
kaum zu fassende frage eben handelt wie
wie diese grenzfragen von von von leben
und tod und da steckt dann glaube ich
eine gefahr darin dass die sache doch
wieder so aufgeheizt wird und man sich
man denkt da steckt jetzt so viel auf
dem spiel das eventuell dann dann
vielleicht am ende gab ein gesetz
zustande aha aber sie sagen einfach so
aufgeheizt ist das thema gar nicht also
das kann man ganz nüchtern betrachten
warum nicht ja also ich glaube dass
diskussion ist natürlich aufgeheizt das
ist das ist das ist klar und ich würde
jetzt auch nicht von vornherein sagen
dass sozusagen jeder der sich da in rage
redet und den hitze redet bei dem bei
dem thema das es dass es unvernünftig
ist ich glaube nur dass man wenn man
wenn man sich halt die angeht ansieht
worum es geht das schon viel auch dafür
spricht ist er als eine pragmatische
frage einer evidenzbasierten
gesundheitspolitik zu sehen wo natürlich
auch fragen fragen von grundsätzlichen
einstellungen intuition auch
weltanschauung bis hin zu religiösen
überzeugungen hineinspielen können aber
letztlich geht es um pragmatische
dramatische abwägungen ob eben maßnahmen
medizinische maßnahmen und und deren
anordnung die prinzipiell glaube ich
darüber müsste konsens herrschen
unbedenklich sind denn das wir haben wir
schließlich impfen und auch im pflichten
für bestimmte krankheiten haben wir ja
auch schon in unserem in unserem werk in
unserem werkzeugkasten und in meinen
augen ist wäre eigentlich man muss das
sich jedenfalls ernsthaft sozusagen
ansehen auch auf der ebene worüber
spricht man eigentlich ob man es nicht
vor allem wirklich mit einer mit einer
sachlichen pragmatischen frage zu tun
hat wo eben nutzen und kosten
abgewogen werden müssen und wo wo die
für die vorstellung ja aber das ist
sowas ist ebenso was ganz ganz intimes
und persönliches wo die analogien dann
zwischen den entsprechenden reaktionen
auf die zumutung sich impfen zu lassen
und den reaktionen auf die frage ist
könnte die am lebensende passieren dass
du an schläuche angeschlossen ist und
nicht mehr weiß wer du bist was soll
dann passieren dass das eben doch unter
unterschiedliche fragen sind die eben
auch unterschiedliche arten von
regelungen also das interessante ist
juristen an dieser stelle weisen er
immer auf den erheblichen eingriff in
die körperliche unversehrtheit hin
würden sie das eigentlich in frage
stellen vielleicht jetzt mal wenn es
schon aufräumen dass er ganz auf die
frage ist eben was ist da erheblich und
da würde ich dann eben sagen da muss
diese frage was erheblich ist natürlich
nicht ohne
rückfrage sozusagen was wird als
erheblich gefunden von den adressaten
dann dieser im flag also von den
personen die dann geimpft werden sollen
was wird von den als erheblich empfunden
das muss natürlich schon hinein spielen
aber ob eben dieser eingriff erheblich
ist oder nicht das finde ich es zunächst
mal eine frage des medizinischen risikos
über die uns ärzten auskunft geben
müssen und
und da bin ich jetzt natürlich ein
absoluter absoluter laie aber ich fühle
mich persönlich jedenfalls aber dann
auch wenn ich wenn ich mich frage kann
ich mir das vorstellen dass sowas
angeordnet wird als pflicht auch für
leute die das eigentlich eher unangenehm
ist unangenehm empfinden kann ich das
eigentlich nicht als so ganz besonders
erheblich einschätzen aber interessant
finde ich eben was jetzt diese
juristische diskussion angeht dass man
ja diesen erheblichkeit begriff auch
durchaus anders auffüllen kann und da
gab es jetzt gerade vor ein paar tagen
auf dem verfassungs blog man dich so
eine anregende diskussion wo dann die
staatsrechtler ute sacksofsky von der
universität frankfurt dann die die these
vertreten hat dass es eben doch auch
medizinisch alt und dann aber mit den
folgen für das recht hat ganz stark
darauf ankommt wie das subjektiv
empfunden wird von der person die sich
in form unterziehen soll und sie sagt
eben wenn jemand das als verabreichung
von gift empfindet davon überzeugt ist
es wird mit ihm etwas gemacht das so ist
als würde er vergiftet dann muss das
ernst genommen werden und muss ein gehen
auch in die in die frage soll der staat
so was überhaupt überhaupt an
anordnungen und da kann man ja sagen das
wirklich das empfinden ja wirklich eine
zutiefst subjektive erfahrung ist wir
können ja auch mal an dieser stelle
recht deutlich den vergleich zum
beispiel also wirklich immer wieder
erstaunlich wie was leute sozusagen in
sich hinein tun ja das ist ja ein
ähnlicher vorgang ob man es nun
sozusagen oral einnimmt oder dann über
die spritze an unterschiedlichen
medikamenten die womöglich auch neu auf
dem markt sind ja die die aber ganz
erhebliche nebenwirkungen haben also
laut des beipackzettels nun also da gibt
es natürlich eine mitunter eine riesige
diskrepanz zwischen der leichtigkeit mit
der sowas verabreicht und eingenommen
wird und auf der anderen seite der
vehemenz mit der man sich gegen diesen
so genannten pigs wert aber wie valide
finden sie denn dieses argument also die
haben sie auch das ist auf die
subjektive empfindung
ankommen muss ich glaube dass das eben
letztlich bei dieser frage der prüfung
der verhältnismäßigkeit also ist das
eine maßnahme die letztlich dem
gemeinwohl jetzt wird durch aber
verstanden als das wohl aller einzelnen
also aller bürger und auch nicht bürger
die sich ja auch in deutschland
aufhalten das also dem wohl aller dieser
person letztlich mehr gedient ist wenn
man die wenn man eben die impfpflicht
einführt als wenn man die dinge laufen
lässt und zu uns zu regeln versucht ja
durch mit anderen auch ja in andere
freiheiten sehr stark ein greifenden
maßnahmen bei dieser abwägung glaube ich
kann letztlich diese diese persönliche
empfindung nicht
in dem sinne den ausschlag geben
jedenfalls wie die frau sacksofsky das
so andeutet sozusagen je stärker diese
empfindung ist und auch das je weniger
vermittelt mit dem was die wissenschaft
was die experten sagen desto ernster
muss das genommen werden also so spitzt
sie das eigentlich zu so dass es fast so
einer frage der glaubensfreiheit wird
dass jemand nutzern das ist ein einiger
schwerer schaden sein müsste für uns als
rechtsstaat wenn sie jetzt leute zwingen
eben sich dieser behandlung zu
unterziehen die für sie so was
furchtbares ist wie wenn jemand eben der
glaubt ein kopftuch tragen zu müssen
gezwungen wird das kopftuch abzunehmen
oder ähnliche religiösen pflichten und
ich glaube dass hineinzunehmen eben in
die abwägung einer einer einer maßnahme
wurst letztlich um ein für und wider von
von
evidenzbasierter evidenz begründeter
anordnungen geht wo unser soziales leben
auf einer auf einer faktischen
physischen ebene so geregelt werden muss
dass all diese ansteckungen soweit wie
möglich runter gefahren werden das ist
das ist schwierig das da einzubringen
bei letztlich glaube ich rüber wir hier
sprechen dass das heißt nicht dass man
keine grundrechte hat wenn man wenn man
dem staat begegnet als als einem als
eine instanz die die medizinische an
anordnungen trifft aber letztlich geht
es hierbei dieser bei dieser muss diese
verhaltens mäßigkeit prüfung muss eben
doch verallgemeinernd und
pauschalisierend vorgenommen werden und
in der hauptsache glaube ich geht es da
bei umfragen wo dann wir alle nicht dass
die unfehlbar sind oder dass die sich
nicht auch streiten aber wo wir
letztlich darauf angewiesen sind uns
erklären zu lassen von den ärzten
statistikern usw wie sind die da die
erwarteten wirkungen und da muss
letztlich geht es ja halt und
medizinischer maßnahmen und wenn die
ärzte sagen dass die dass die risiken
die mit eigentlich medizinischen risiken
dieser dieser dieser impfungen so
minimal sind eben doch gar nicht
irgendwie erheblich abweichen von den
von risiken von impfungen in anderen
fällen dann glaube ich dass letztlich
doch diese empfindlichkeiten einfach da
nicht durchschlagen können sie haben
gesagt das ganze verfahren könnte jetzt
diese diskussion auch noch weiter
emotionalisieren weiter auf also von
quasi dieser nüchternen
wissenschaftlichen ebene hochheben zu
einem sehr emotionalen
zu einer sehr emotionalen diskussion am
ist es dafür ehrlich gesagt nicht auch
längst zu spät denn ist nicht grün am
das kind schon im brunnen gefallen
dadurch dass man ein jahr lang hinweg
immer wieder auch in situationen wo es
noch gar nicht eine rolle spielte aber
wieder penetrant darauf hingewiesen hat
dass es die nicht geben ja ja völlig
richtig dadurch ist dadurch ist eben
glaube ich auch 1 1 ein falscher
eindruck und also wirklich so eine art
kollektive einbildung entstanden
ebendiese diese impfpflicht wäre
eigentlich dass ganz furchtbares wäre
was ganz gruseliges und quer durch alle
parteien muss man ehrlicherweise seine
aussagen so lind nachdem es jetzt
gegebene zelle gehalten wird hat da dann
schon so eine art konsens eben auch dass
dozenten unseres liberalen regimes das
in der tat eigentlich natürlich
unangenehme pflichten für jedermann
vermeiden möchte ausgesprochen aber dass
das glaube ich in der tat auch dass
dieses merkwürdige umgehen dieses thema
hat dadurch hatte das auch so eine
bekannte eine symbolische bedeutung ist
wurde es wurde sozusagen so diese fahne
ins fenster gingen vertraut uns
da es bei uns in guten händen denn im
pflicht mehr haben ja gar nicht in frage
nicht mehr richtig reagiert genau nicht
mal durch die hintertür naja und dadurch
ist in der tat hat die dart leider haben
haben jetzt so zeitig spitzenpolitiker
also diejenigen die dann doch so den ton
auch angeben
spitzenpolitiker möglicherweise auch
medien das müsste man sich dann noch mal
ansehen da haben schon haben jetzt eine
verantwortung dafür dass es schwieriger
ist darüber so zu sanktionen zu
diskutieren weil die sache zu so einem
kuriosen kopien zu seiner symbolischen
moralischen frage aufgebauscht worden
ist so dass es war geradezu tabu wir
haben ein tabu installiert wir haben so
getan als wäre das vernünftig zu sagen
impfpflicht auf keinen fall dran rühren
und dann ende letzten jahres gab es halt
immer mehr leute die die dann
nachgefragten moment mal warum ist das
soll das einst so selbstverständlich
sein was spricht denn jetzt eigentlich
gegen die impfpflicht und dann kam die
diskussion zum glück ins rollen und wann
wie ging es ihnen denn eigentlich waren
sie schon sehr viel früher dafür oder
mir also wirklich nur so in dem sinne
dass ich mich gibt es mir so
gelegentlich durch den durch den durch
den kopf ging das sich dass ich mich
dann fragte warum wird das wird das also
als evident
behandelt also kann ich mich jetzt nicht
irgendwie brüsten denn dann hätte ich ja
schon mal den entsprechenden artikel
schreiben müssen und ich bin auch nicht
gemacht da irgendwas besonders früh
erkannt zu haben aber ich habe dann zum
beispiel auch mal bei uns in der
redaktionskonferenz die kollegen von
natur und wissen scheint die ja die ja
die jetzt ja seit über zwei jahren eben
eine ganz wunderbare weise eben diese
zeit die berichterstattung über die
naturwissenschaftlich medizinische weise
schon noch immer mit beurteilungen für
die maßnahmen verbinden sie wieder
andere jochen müller jung und die
kollegen da auch mal gefragt eben in der
konferenz ja ist das nicht etwas
merkwürdig dass das dass das so gar
nicht irgendwie zur sprache kommt und
damals im letzten herbst waren die eben
auch noch der ansicht der planer ist
glaube ich kein redaktionsgeheimnis aus
weil es daher auch entsprechend artikel
gab da waren sie eben der ansicht dass
man doch eben sehr stark die auch
sozialwissenschaftlichen gründe
berücksichtigen müsse die aufsichten
studie neben belegen lassen dass diese
art von von zwangsmaßnahmen
kontraproduktiv sein weil sie halt erst
dann nicht alle leute wirklich erreichen
es wird eben nicht folgt von von allen
wenn sowas wenn sowas verordnet wird und
zweitens dass eben auch dieser dieser
effekt des kontraproduktiven durch
anordnung also dieses muss man jetzt mal
so schlagwortartig die spaltung der
gesellschaft wird gesteigert also da
muss man schon sagen für diese argumente
gab es auch nach auskunft eben unsere
naturwissenschaftlichen kollegen
wirklich auch auch diskutierens werte
sozialwissenschaftliche argumente ich
würde jetzt mal im rückblick sagen die
man muss jetzt eben wenn wir unsere
empirie haben der diskussion die wir
miterlebt haben dass es eben doch auch
andere effekte gab und insbesondere eben
dieser effekt bei denen wir gerade
sprachen dass das der sache als tabu
behandelt worden ist so getan worden ist
als dürfte man da überhaupt nicht dran
dran rühren das hat ja auch das dazu
geführt dass dann glaube ich jedenfalls
schienen mir plausibel dass sich da
viele leute so ein geld haben diejenigen
die sowieso die maßnahmen skeptisch
sehen gesagt haben hier wird ja
zugegeben hier ist was was der staat auf
gar keinen fall tun kann und zu hier
werden wir ruhig gehalten und so und die
anderen maßnahmen wo die intention war
das gesagt ich mag keine impfpflicht
aber alles andere ist ja nicht so
schlimm wie impfpflicht dem könnt ihr
euch beugen ich glaube es gibt auch die
reaktion das dann genau umgekehrt zu
bewerten und zu sagen ja die müssen ja
zugeben impfpflicht geht nicht also dass
geben sie immer hinzu
aber die ab die anderen maßnahmen
wirklich eben wirklich milder sind und
wirklich besser und so weiter das liegt
ja gar nicht auf der hand ich halte aber
nochmal dagegen wisse was ich ganz
interessant fand oder ist es immer
spannend mal dem klick sozusagen von
deutschland zu lösen und weltweit zu
gehen und wir haben jetzt usa uns auch
schon
angeguckt die ja auch sehr vehement
darüber streiten auch mit dem ergebnis
gerade beschrieben haben aus anderen
gründen aber die sind ja auch
interessant ich habe mal jetzt einen
seite koordiniert die erschienen ist am
dienstag die kann ich auch gerne in die
schule zu tun wo wir einfach mal die
korrespondenten gebeten haben den stand
der diskussionen in ihren jeweiligen
regionen
darzulegen und ich muss sagen die was
mich wirklich überrascht hat wie
singulär die allgemeine impfpflicht auf
der welt tatsächlich ist ich habe
gelernt ecuador war das erste land das
es eingeführt hat aber die südamerikaner
haben auch sowieso eine sehr hohe
impfquoten 80 prozent und plus ja da ist
viel das insofern auch gar nicht ins
gewicht weil es eh nicht durchgesetzt
oder wir haben jetzt österreich als land
erstes land in europa das die einsätze
und
jetzt aber auch schon gesagt haben die
eigentliche kontrolle die verschieben
wir mal als später das wird wieder
aufleben wenn man sie tatsächlich mal
brauchen oder dann wird sie erst
relevant für den herbst wir haben
russland ganz interessant ja da ist gibt
es eine impfpflicht auf regionalebene
aber putin stellt sich hin und sagt wir
fühlen gar keine ein ja und auch die
haben eine über den arbeitgeber
inszeniert china zb auch ganz spannend
machen auch keine form eine impfpflicht
aber gegenüber den sozialen druck da
kommen die leute in denen die impf
trupps kommen in die betriebe und dann
werde ich denjenigen mal sehen der dann
sagt mache ich nicht mit also irritiert
also mich muss ich sagen irritiert dass
in der tat auch so dass es eben nicht
nur debatte ist die in deutschland sehr
wie mint geführt sondern auch
international und ist es nicht doch ein
zeichen dafür dass so irrational sie
vielleicht sein oder ist die debatte
aber oder die bedenken dagegen aber so
menschlich und international verbreitet
ist sie gleichzeitig
ja also man sieht man sieht daran
natürlich dass es sich sozusagen es ist
versteht sich jetzt keineswegs von
selbst also eine so eine in flieden das
ist es nicht mehr es ist nicht nur eine
maßnahme die man sozusagen wenn man nur
genau hingeht
dann in jedem gesetzbuch der welt finden
wird so wie du sollst nicht töten das
ist wahrscheinlicher doch eine universal
die man in allen rechtsordnung
findet und und da sieht man sicherlich
zweierlei dran also man sieht daran dass
das bei der wahl der einführung von von
normen oder auch schon von mechanismen
die die ohne das ausdrücklich eine
pflicht statuiert wird eben doch dann
durch die berühmte hintertür was ihr
auch milderes mittel ist durch schaffung
von anreizen eben soll dieses gewünschte
ergebnis erreicht werden dass es da in
großen spielraum von möglichkeiten gibt
und dass da würde ich aber auch sagen so
wie ich eben gesagt habe man muss diese
frage was ist in form sinnvoll und ist
die anordnung von impfungen sinnvoll so
pragmatisch und empirisch wie möglich
behandelt genau das gleiche würde ich
allerdings auch für diese rechts
methodische oder theoretische frage
sagen auch die frage ist ein enorm
sinnvoll muss man auch so empirisch
empirie gestützt wie möglich und dann in
der tat auch mit der frage wie sieht es
dann aus mit der bevölkerungs
bereitschaft beantworten und ich glaube
auch das würde ich unbedingt zu geben
auch als befürworter einer impfpflicht
man sieht an dieser großen regelungs
breite dass es eben doch jetzt sage ich
jetzt auch in erweiterung dessen was ich
eben gesagt habe dass diese analogie
eben mit den mit den ethischen
diskussion anderen politischen fragen
vielleicht zumindest insofern
zutrifft als es eben eine eine frage ist
wo es wo es halt um den um den
menschlichen leib und eben auch das den
einzelnen ganz ganz persönlich geht und
wo dann auch eben der umgang der der
staatlichen und ja auch der medizinisch
wissenschaftliche bürokratischen
apparate mit ihnen auf eine weise
geregelt werden muss das natürlich dass
das individuum jetzt nicht unter die
räder gerät insofern glaube ich zum
beispiel das möchte ich dann auch gerne
sagen dass ich finde diese formulierung
es ist nun fix
die ist nur schein rationalen so die
finde ich unglücklich ist polemik und
wenn man sieht was für ein unsinn eben
von impfgegnern verbreitet wird kann man
verstehen dass da polemisch dagegen
gehalten wird aber das ist natürlich
eigentlich quatsch das ist eigentlich
auch nicht medizinisch zu vertreten denn
wenn es jetzt nur ein pieks im sinne von
harmlos und folgenlos wäre müsste es ja
gar nicht gemacht werden natürlich wird
eine substanz injiziert die ganz schön
viel verändert der man ganz schön viel
dann schon viel zutraut und insofern
nämlich die
immunreaktion des körpers anzukurbeln
also vielleicht um das deutlich zu sagen
die substanz geht dann auch schnell
wieder raus aber sie hat eben im körper
die immunantwort er herausgekitzelt die
dann schützen soll das vielleicht einmal
zu einer ordnung ich bin ja und ich und
insofern ja insofern sollte unseres
schon zu denken geben was sie was sie
was sie sagen und ich finde das auch
immer hilfreich in den in diesen
ethischen fragen dass man sich eben dass
man sich ja so ansieht in einen anderen
ländern ist ist eben auch die
sterbehilfe oder die abtreibung anders
geregelt so lange man sich eben auch
trotzdem natürlich noch das eigene
urteil letztlich vorbehält hier würde
ich allerdings sagen geht es eben
weniger dann um ein eigenes urteil in so
einem sondern ganz grundsätzlichen sinne
wo man vielleicht auch aufgrund von
deutscher rechts tradition abwehr eben
der wiederholung von von euthanasie
schon im vorfeld und so weiter zum
beispiel bei der sterbehilfe vielleicht
meint gute gründe zu haben eine andere
regelung hier in deutschland zu treffen
als in holland oder in in der schweiz
hier würde ich bei der bei der impfung
würde ich eben hoffnung mehr bei den bei
den tatsachen ansetzen zu können als bei
solchen ethischen überlegungen und dann
eben
zu gucken wir müssen aber dann auch
sehen im internationalen vergleich haben
wir eben trotz unserem wunderbaren
musterknaben image was für die
organisation von allem möglichen angeht
was ja sowieso vielleicht schon recht
ramponiert jetzt ist in der in der
pandemie aber haben wir halt hier doch
diese diese im vergleich mit den ländern
jedenfalls mit denen wir uns gerne
vergleichen erstaunlich bedenklich
niedrige impfquote insofern ist es dann
zeit auch nicht verwunderlich dass man
hier jetzt nun auch zu diesen zu diesem
den ersten blick so harten mittel dieser
allgemeine impfpflicht greift
japan das dann würde ich sagen setzen
wir jetzt mal einen punkt was die
impfpflicht angeht obwohl man natürlich
vieles vertiefen könnte insbesondere
welche neue dynamik omikron und alle
möglichen neuen varianten
dazu beitragen muss man ehrlicherweise
immer als disclaimer sagen weil ich
denke da wird sonst der eine oder andere
hörer die eine oder andere hören da auch
noch darauf hinweisen das ist natürlich
auch noch etwas was die debatte
maßgeblich beeinflussen kann aber was
wir jetzt machen wollen ist noch mal zu
einem ganz anderen thema kommen zu dem
wir uns auch eigentlich verabredet haben
ja war das nämlich über den stream court
wollten wir auch einen kurzen schlenker
zu der verstorbenen legendären richterin
ruth bader ginsburg machen gerade wird
nämlich ihre bibliothek ersteigert was
welche schätze verbergen sich da ja das
ist die bibliothek der eheleute muss
peter ginsberg und martin ginsburg
martin ginsburg war auch ein jurist auch
ein professor spezialist für steuerrecht
auch anwalt hat dann aber seine
tätigkeit aufgegeben als seine frau dann
nach washington als bundesrichterin
gegangen ist und ich finde es schön wenn
man sich eben wenn man diesen katalog da
im auktionshaus bonham's
wenn man das elektronisch durchblättert
das sind also 166 lose wobei viele lose
dann wie das wie das üblich ist so
konvolute aus zehn bis 15 titeln dass
man ebenso das ganze leben eigentlich
dieser dieser beiden juristen die
natürlich auch gebildete menschen waren
und auch klassiker der weltliteratur
oder der in ihrer zeit
entstandenen literatur daneben auch so
im bücherschrank hatten dass man das
alles eben so zu sagen jetzt dass man
daran vorbei geht und sich eigentlich
ebendieses dieses ganze leben
aufblättert und was natürlich dann noch
besonders ins auge fällt sind ist
einerseits eine natürlich juristisch
nicht nur fachliteratur sondern dann
auch bücher von kollegen die dann später
ginsberg als der großen pionieren
insbesondere auf das recht der
gleichberechtigung dann ihre bücher
gewidmet haben und das gleiche gilt eben
auch für den feminismus also man findet
viele büchern von klassik gerinnen des
feminismus in dieser bibliothek zum teil
bücher die eben frau ginsburg sich
selbst natürlich besorgt hat um sie dann
zu lesen um sich dabei diesem
lebensthema weiterzubilden aber später
dann eben auch bücher eben von von
feministischen
schriftstellerinnen und aktivistinnen
die dann sich bedankt haben bei ihr und
ihr eben ihre bücher gewinnen und was
schlechter so heraus können sie schlecht
für das eine oder andere mal nennen was
da besonders interessant scheint
ja also besonders schön sind natürlich
dann dinge wenn man wenn man sieht da da
wird auch so eine persönliche seine
persönliche leidenschaft insbesondere in
diese widmung gelegt also von ginsberg
scheint dann schon die art von genauer
leserin zu sein die jetzt nicht
unbedingt viel rum krebs in ihren
büchern also es gibt auch literatur aus
ihrer studienzeit da hat sie auch an
streichungen also randnotizen und so
weiter wie man das ja vielleicht auch
selber noch kennt aus seinen seinen
lehrbüchern aber es ist nicht die art
von bibliothek jetzt eines eines
bedeutenden menschen wo vielleicht eine
universitätsbibliothek sich deswegen
bemühen würde die bücher zu erwerben
weil sie dann kritische anmerkungen
gemacht hat aber eben von diesen von
diesem individuellen dieser dieser
dieser exemplare
da ja da sieht man dann zum beispiel mal
die die also was ist denn die autoren
und autorinnen dann zum ausdruck bringen
die halt die eben dann sich sich bei
ginsberg
bedanken da hat man einmal manchen ein
buch von ihrem kollegen stephen stephen
breyer
der der ihr dann ein widmung auf die auf
die titelseite schreibt und sozusagen
die ganze seite dann nutzt um das sucht
und das so voll zu kritzeln genügte auf
man nicht einfach nur sagen hier viel
spaß damit oder vielen dank für alles
sondern hat sich dann da so ins zeug
gelegt dass es dann fast so zu sagen so
vom grafischen wald zwar natürlich auch
einen durchaus
systematischer denker ist aber auch
jemand der der häufig auch so um ecken
denkt einen auch so überrascht auch so
in den mündlichen verhandlungen häufig
die anwälte überrascht mit mit fragen
die so ein bisschen um die ecke kommen
und na ja man soll ja in grabow logi
vielleicht nicht allzu viel hinein legen
aber wenn man das eben aufblättert und
dann sieht dass der ebenso wirklich
kritzelt dass er voll gekritzelt hat die
so diese leere seite passt das dann doch
zu diesem typus jurist der ist und sie
haben ja auch mit geboten ich werde ihn
noch überlegen morgen geht's morgen geht
es zu ende ich muss aber jetzt schon ich
bin ja bin ja eben kein jurist und viele
juristen verdienen ja sehr gut dass dann
auch jetzt schon an den geboten die da
die da abgegeben worden sind in den usa
also mein traum wäre vielleicht gewesen
doch eines der bücher zu bekommen von
den kollegen von von rosberg ins burgund
und installieren der ja der der der wort
mächtigste konservative am gericht war
und den trotzdem also eine wirkliche
enge persönliche freundschaft weil sie
zum beispiel auch die liebe zur oper
verband die mittelstädte ginsburg
verbunden hat und eskaliere hat eben
seine seine prinzipien der der
interpretation immer wieder auch in
büchern niedergelegt und da gibt es zum
beispiel eins eben mit zur persönlicher
widmung wo er dann außer nicht nur was
auf die titelseite geschrieben hat
sondern dann auch noch in dem buch
rundbrief drinsteckt auf dem supreme
court briefpapier und da steht dann
einfach nur die großfeuer sammer reading
und das ist dann ein buch wie richter
argumentieren
im sommer in den ferien kannst du mal
gucken rentiert das finde ich jetzt
einfach herrlich hinterher lakonie aber
da habe ich schon gesehen diese bücher
von scully aus verständlichen gründen
der steckt dann irgendwie doch so drin
das kostet mehrere 1000 dollar ich
glaube das wird mein budget
überschreiten aber es gibt auch es gibt
zum beispiel bücher zur geschichte von
brooklyn wo sie aufgewachsen ist es gibt
hier eine einer illustratoren vom vom
new yorker maria carmen mit der mit der
sie offenbar auch eine freundschaft
verbunden hat also da zum beispiel denke
ich da da werde ich vielleicht mein
glück versuchen in der tat wirklich
schön wie das einleben dann abbilden
kann er leben in büchern herr banas
schön dass wir diesen schlenker gemacht
haben auch noch über die bibliothek von
ruth bader ginsburg und vor allen dingen
natürlich ihre vertieften ausführungen
zu im pflicht da wird es in der tat noch
weitergehen ich kann schon mal
ankündigen meine kollegen reinhard
müller und stephan klenner werden auch
noch zusammen an einem spezial arbeiten
dass wir dann wahrscheinlich in den
nächsten tagen oder wochen hier auf
diesem kanal veröffentlicht werden also
die debatte wird weitergehen herzlichen
dank herr bahners ich danke ihnen
so das war unser kleiner ausflug in die
vereinigten staaten an den supreme court
und jetzt geht es wieder zurück ans
bundesverwaltungsgericht also zurück
nach deutschland nach leipzig und da hat
es eben eine interessante entscheidung
gegeben
bezüglich der bds bewegung erzähl doch
mal pia worum ging es da so das
bundesverwaltungsgericht eben in leipzig
hatte über einen beschluss der stadt
münchen zu entscheiden die stadt münchen
hat nämlich im jahr 2017 verboten das
oder beschlossen das städtische
räumlichkeiten nicht mehr zur verfügung
gestellt werden wenn dort die bds
bewegung diskutiert werden soll oder
irgendetwas im zusammenhang mit der bse
bewegung die bds bewegung wir haben es
im intro schon so ein bisschen gesagt
beschäftigt keineswegs so die stadt
münchen sondern sehr sehr viele kommunen
und sogar auch den deutschen bundestag
seit 2009 10 deswegen kommen wir das
euch heute mal mitgebracht also die bds
bewegung wäre es schon gesagt will sich
für menschenrechte der palästinenser
einsetzen und zwar auf gewaltfreie art
ruft aber zum boykott israelischer waren
zum beispiel auf also stellt sich auch
vor vor geschäfte die israelische waren
verkaufen und so weiter und ist deshalb
sehr sehr umstritten wird als
antisemitisch angesehene genau der
bundestag hat da eine sehr umstrittene
und vielleicht auch sehr ungewöhnliche
entscheidung getroffen die hat nämlich
diese bewegung der sicherheits
antisemitisch eingestuft wir hatten
darüber auch schon mal gesprochen bzw du
und die kolleginnen hélène bobrowski
haben auch darüber gesprochen vor
einigen monaten schon das war die folge
181 genau vom 13 oktober genau das thema
hat uns hier schon ein bisschen
beschäftigt und interessanterweise schon
da haben wir ja einmal diskutiert was
das eigentlich für konsequenzen hat wenn
der bundestag seine
einordnung macht hatte eigentlich dieser
münchner fall vielleicht sollten wir das
vorher erklären der war ja zeitlich
davor also dieser bundestagsbeschluss
resultiert aus dem jahr 2009 10 und der
besteht aus münchen ist schon aus 2017
das heißt er hatte mit den 2009 10 der
beschluss des deutschen bundestags
überhaupt nichts zu tun obwohl das thema
eigentlich dasselbe ist der bundestag
hat nämlich im jahr 2019 beschlossen
also was auch immer das genau bedeuten
so dass jetzt kein gesetz oder so die
haben einfach gesagt wir finden jetzt
dass eben die bds bewegung sich
antisemitisch äußern und dass man den
wir als als bundestag und auch als
aufruf an die bundesregierung denen
keine räumlichkeiten und einrichtungen
zur verfügung stellen sollen und keine
projekte finanziell fördern sollten die
das existenzrecht israels infrage
stellen und der deutsche bundestag hat
ihm damals auch gesagt liebe länder
städte und gemeinden wir rufen euch dazu
auf euch diese haltung anzuschließen so
im prinzip ist genau das passiert in
münchen allerdings wieder richtig sagst
das war schon zwei jahre früher in
münchen hatte die stadt schon zwei jahre
früher im jahr 2017 gesagt wir möchten
nicht räumlichkeiten hier irgendwie
vergeben städtische räumlichkeiten an
die bds bewegung so also und zwar
irgendwie an alles was die bds kampagne
unterstützt verfolgt oder für diese
wirkt so also schon relativ generell so
und hat sich jetzt die bds dagegen
gewehrt sollte man meinen dem war aber
nicht so sondern es wehrte sich ein
münchner bürger dagegen und zwar ein
pensionierter physiker der hat dann 2018
beantragt des stadtmuseums eine
podiumsdiskussion über genau diesen
beschluss der stadt münchen zu
veranstalten unter dem motto wie sehr
schränkt münchen die meinungsfreiheit
einen der stadtratsbeschluss vom 13
dezember 2017 und dann hat die stadt
deswegen ist das jetzt echt so ein
bisschen von hinten durch die brust ins
auge dass abgelegten hat gesagt hier nix
veranstaltungen unter verweis auf eben
diesen beschluss aus 2017 argument also
da geht es ja um die bds bewegung und
die sanya hatte weiß ich die katze in
den schwanz ja genau die hat sich total
in den schwanz gebissen und der physiker
hat dagegen geklagt vom
verwaltungsgericht auch verloren aber in
zweiter instanz und jetzt auch vor dem
bundesverwaltungsgericht mit erfolg
geklagt zumindest für einen anderen saal
das ist aber ein bisschen irrelevant
also diese andere seite steht für
podiumsdiskussion aller art zur
verfügung und da hat das
bundesverwaltungsgericht gesagt ich
zitiere jetzt mal kurz die beschränkung
des widmung des umfangs einer kommunalen
öffentlichen einrichtungen die deren
nutzung allein aufgrund der befassung
mit einem bestimmten thema ausschließt
verletzt das grundrecht der
meinungsfreiheit das ist tatsächlich ein
wie ich finde sehr sehr gründlich
grundsätzlicher satz auch wenn das
urteil noch nicht vorliegt sondern wir
bisher nur eine pressemitteilung haben
also das bundesverwaltungsgericht hat
festgestellt dass laut der widmung
dächer der stadt dieser saal genutzt
werden durfte für kommunalpolitische
diskussionsveranstaltung alle gut und
dann hat sie hat das
bundesverwaltungsgericht gericht gesagt
dieser stadtratsbeschluss aus zwei 17er
sagt bitte nix was mit der bds bewegung
zu tun hat sei eine nachträgliche
beschränkungen dieses widmung umfangs
und diese sei rechtswidrig und unwirksam
weil sie das grundrecht auf
meinungsfreiheit verletzt also eingriff
ist glaube ich natürlich wird in die
rechte von bürgern massiv eingegriffen
wenn die keine städtischen
räumlichkeiten nutzen dürfen und das
bundesverwaltungsamt eben in die
meinungsäusserungsfreiheit natürlich
genau das hat das
bundesverwaltungsgericht sehr sehr nahe
es ging nur um artikel 5 also da haben
sie auch tatsächlich sehr deutlich
gesagt dass es verfassungsrechtlich
nicht gerechtfertigt und zwar quasi
einmal aus formellen gründen weil
artikel 5 eben nur der beschränkung also
den schranken allgemeiner gesetze
unterliegt ein stadtratsbeschluss wissen
kein formelles gesetz und die leipziger
richter sagen auch es gibt auch keine
irgendwie in anderem sinne allgemeine
regelung die jetzt wie ein formelles
gesetz wirken würde und dieser beschluss
sei eben auch nicht meinungs- neutral
ja das kann das gehör man genauso
freundlich ausgedrückt zu sagen und das
bundesverwaltungsgericht schließt sich
da offensichtlich der zweiten instanz an
die das auch schon sehr deutlich gesagt
haben das sozusagen ein solcher
beschluss irgendwie einer einer krassen
rechtfertigung bedürfte also zum schutz
von rechtsgütern die schlechthin ohne
rücksicht auf eine bestimmte meinung zu
schützen werden lernt dass das
bundesverwaltungsgericht und sagt dann
sehr das wäre nur denkbar wenn quasi die
meinungsäußerungen die geistiges fähre
verlassen würden und in rechtsgut
verletzungen oder erkennbar in
gefährdungslagen umschlagen würden also
quasi wenn aus der theorie dass ich eben
diskutiere über irgendwas so sei es
jetzt eben auch über irgendetwas was man
für antisemitisch halten mag wenn daraus
praxis werden würde oder zumindest
aufrufe zu gewalt oder irgendwas und
dafür gibt es halt keinerlei
anhaltspunkte zumal ja in diesem fall
noch nicht mal die bds bewegung selbst
diskutieren wollte sondern dieser bürger
eben über diesen beschluss über die bds
bewegung diskutieren wollte also das
bundesverwaltungsgericht wird da finde
ich ungewohnt deutlich und sagt dass das
geht auf gar keinen fall ganz klare
verletzung der meinung der
meinungsfreiheit und da habe ich mich
schon sind die wissen dann gewundert
dass dann als ich meine was heißt
gewundert der antisemitismus beauftragte
der bundesregierung hat danach so ein
bisschen gesagt naja ist ja eine
einzelfall entscheidung ist ja eine
spezifische konstellation aus münchen
und die kommunen sollten mal weiterhin
irgendwie schön prüfen ob sie denn der
bds veranstaltungen den öffentlichen
räumlichkeiten verweigern können jede
einzelne verwaltung müsste das sorgsam
prüfen ehrlich gesagt dass sie ich schon
anders natürlich war das jetzt eine
spezifische konstellation weil es quasi
über den umweg eines klagenden bürgers
war und nicht eine klage der pds
bewegung selbst an dieser
grundsätzlichen argumentation des
bundesverwaltungsgerichtes halt aber
überhaupt nichts also das ist schon sehr
grundsätzlich und wenn man davon ausgeht
dass sich das bundesverwaltungsgericht
hat der zweiten instanz angeschlossen
hat dann geht es auch so ein bisschen in
die richtung dass die sagen na ja also
diese argumentation auf dem aus dem npd
verfahren mit der die stadt münchen
begründet hatte den ausschluss von von
kommunalen räumen die würde halt hier
nicht greifen weil zwar antisemitische
konzepte nicht mit der menschenwürde
vereinbar sind aber das kann halt von
bedeutung sei für parteiverbote oder
vereinsverbote aber das rechtfertigt
selbstverständlich keine sei verbote
durch öffentlich einrichtungen also
kannst du das vielleicht noch mal ein
bisschen klarer machen was mit dem was
im npd urteil konkret vorgegeben war und
wozu man das hätte nicht nutzen können
die stadt münchen hat halte sich quasi
auf das npd urteil berufen als sie
diesen beschluss 2017 erlassen hat und
er hat gesagt antisemitische konzepte
sind nicht mit der menschenwürde
vereinbar und damit verfassungswidrig
und deshalb stellen wir hier keine
räumlichkeiten zur verfügung
und da das bundesverwaltungsgericht also
kann man annehmen die haben sich auf
einmal der zweiten instanz angeschlossen
jetzt sehr deutlich gesagt okay das mag
ja sein dass das irgendwie rassistische
antisemitische was auch immer konzepte
sind aber das kann halt vielleicht dazu
dienen eine partei zu verbieten oder
möglicherweise auch ein verein aber es
kann keine rechtfertigung dafür sein
dass eine kommune sagt hier wir geben
euch keine keine seele mehr um irgendwas
um irgendwas durchzuziehen was euch
nicht passt thematisch denn es ist nun
mal so dass die meinungsfreiheit erstmal
auch rassistische oder antisemitische
oder jugendliche anderen extremistischen
äußerungen umfasst und dieser ansatz von
kommunen den man ja in den letzten
jahren noch sehr verstärkt sieht dass
die quasi im meinungskampf stellung
beziehen wollen indem sie räumlichkeiten
nicht zur verfügung stellen zum beispiel
für npd-veranstaltung und so da kennt
man das ja auch der mag ja irgendwie
ehrenhaft sein und und nett gemeint aber
dieser ansatz ist nicht nur total
unangebracht sondern er ist auch
schlicht verfassungswidrig denn es ist
nicht die aufgabe von von kommunen sich
da in die in die öffentliche debatte
quasi einzumischen na ja also ich könnte
mir vorstellen dass das natürlich also
man sich dann auch frage inwieweit denn
eigentlich steuergeld dafür verbraten
werden soll wenn es tatsächlich um
rassistische und antisemitische
äußerungen geht aber wenn ich das
richtig verstehe ist eigentlich dass die
titel um gar nicht so sehr sozusagen das
zuzulassen sondern eher dass man das im
vorhinein nicht verbieten darf sozusagen
mal prophylaktisch um zu verhindern dass
eventuell
antisemitische äußerungen der stadt
fanden verstehe ich das richtig weil ich
meine umgekehrt muss doch also oder
konkret gefragt muss denn jetzt so eine
kommune tatsächlich dulden dass
antisemitisches gedankengut dann
tatsächlich in so einer veranstaltung
auch geäußert wird also erst mal muss
sie das dulden ja ganz klar das sind es
ist quasi dieses normale problem dass
keine kommune lust hat zum beispiel der
npd in teilen auch der afd
räumlichkeiten zur verfügung zu stellen
und das wiederholt sich hat bundesweit
immer wieder dann sagt die kommune gibt
es nicht dann sagt die partei okay wir
klagen und dann sagt sagen viele
verwaltungsgerichte auch noch nie gibt
es nicht und dann sagen die
oberverwaltungsgerichte und aller spielt
dass uns das bundesverfassungsgericht
immer nein leute das ist nicht euer job
euch als staat darin einzumischen und es
geht einfach nicht darum ob euch
irgendeine meinung nicht passt also so
lange dass keine verbotene organisation
oder partei oder irgendwas ist kann man
nicht einfach daher kommen und sagen wir
finden diese meinung beruf und deshalb
kriegt ihr keine räume mehr das ist halt
einfach ein klarer eingriff in
grundrechte
denn grundrechte sind nunmal
abwehrrechte gegen den staat wie weit
kann denn eigentlich so eine die
veranstaltung selber wenn sie denn mal
läuft dann
eingeschränkt werden naja was brauche
dann nur wenn es tatsächlich irgendwie
ich würde mal sagen zu aufrufen zur
gewalt kommt also natürlich wenn es
jetzt so gewalt käme natürlich natürlich
schon mehr und folgten volksverhetzung
ist während straftatbestand den man da
nicht natürlich nicht dulden muss genau
weil man sich dann im strafrechtlich
relevanten bereich befinden würde aber
solange man über bestimmte dinge
diskutiert und eben nicht so irgendwie
gewalt aufruft oder so hat die stadt da
im prinzip keine mittel und deswegen
fand ich schon schon diese entscheidung
wirklich interessant und und teile eben
da auch nicht die die rechtsauffassung
dass das ein einzelfall entscheidung ist
zumal ja eben auf bundesebene die bds
bewegung auch gegen diesen
bundestagsbeschluss aus 2009 10 von dem
wir schon erzählt haben noch vor geht
die haben verloren vor dem
verwaltungsgericht berlin
und das verwaltungsgericht berlin hat
eben auch gesagt naja dieser lustige
beschluss ist eben auch kein formelles
gesetz sondern eine positionsbestimmung
des deutschen bundestags und der
beschluss greift aus sicht des
verwaltungsgerichts berlin nicht in das
allgemeine persönlichkeitsrecht der
dieser dieser klagen dünnen 1 und das vg
berlin hat auch keinen 1 wenn die
meinungsfreiheit versammlungsfreiheit
oder vereinigungsfreiheit der bds
bewegung gesehen und die haben da gesagt
na ja das ist ja irgendwie schon gar
kein richtiger eingriff in dem
bundestagsbeschluss weil eingreifen
würden ja erst die kommunen und für die
bds könnte es zwar ein schwieriger
werden räume für veranstaltungen zu
kriegen denn das war ja genau der aufruf
den der bundestag dann gestartet hat
aber dagegen keine der pds ja dann immer
auch erfolgreich klagen finde ich jetzt
ein bisschen schräg und sehr formal
argumentiert also der anwalt der bds
bewegung hatte auch schon gesagt dass er
da durch alle instanzen ziehen möchte
und meines erachtens hat er daraus
leipzig jetzt gerade echt futter
bekommen um quasi sozusagen seine
rechtsmittel zu begründen
[Musik]
also kritik muss anders geäußert werden
als ihr durch eine generelle
behinderung an aktivität das muss man
vielleicht man so konstatiert auch hier
übrigens wieder weil es inzwischen
wirklich wunderbar klappt wir laden zur
diskussion ein zuhörer feedback ja wer
immer sich da wie berufen will führt
vielleicht auch eine andere meinung hat
und überhaupt das mal einordnen möchte
wir haben sie jetzt relativ neutral vor
getragen er kann da gerne schreiben an
faz einspruch
faz.de oder auch auf unserer
internetseite den einen oder anderen
kommentar hinterlassen ja dann belassen
wir es jetzt mal bei diesem thema würde
ich sagen geld hinkommt zu der
hauptstadt und der test strategie
ja und da kümmern wir uns jetzt um mal
wieder eine sehr skurrile
konstellation aus der hauptstadt erklärt
übrigens nicht die generelle knappheit
von pcr test über die wir hier
diskutieren ja also das vielleicht nur
als kleiner disclaimer vorneweg
zeigt aber auch dass die politik nicht
unbedingt clevere sachen tut um das
problem zu beheben würde ich mal sagen
also man könnte sogar noch weiter gehen
und festhalten sie fügt dem ganzen
problemen auch noch neue hinzu
ja so traurig ist es trust avaya mit
einem kollegen schon geschrieben über
das thema ich fand es sehr schön da
lautete einsatz im teaser ein lehrstück
über verfehlte planwirtschaft
genau was ist da los in berlin warum
stehen die leute fünf stunden in der
schlange da ist ein artikel den ich
zusammen mit dem kollegen sebastian
balzter in der sonntagszeitung
veröffentlicht habe da kann ich auch mal
einen link in die show zu tun vielleicht
ein kleiner hinweis dieser artikel ist
hinter der bezahlschranke und auch da
wieder der aufruf wer uns unterstützen
möchte also auch diesen podcast ist
herzlich eingeladen ein abo
abzuschließen entweder für die
allgemeine faz für unser f + format oder
auch für den faz einspruch alles ist
willkommen alles hilft uns so und nun
also zu berlin und der test strategie
hier ja also wie gesagt man sieht er
hier sehr
unvorteilhafte sehen vor den
landeseigenen test stellen ewige
schlangen und die von leuten die sich ja
krank venen ja und deswegen auf einen
pcr-test warten man muss vielleicht dazu
noch mal sagen was sind das für leute
die da vor der tür stehen das sind die
unterschiedlichsten konstellationen wir
haben ja einerseits die verpflichtung
noch mal ein pcr test zu machen also
bisher hatten wir die verpflichtung
jedenfalls bevor wir in die absolute
knappheit hatten haben wir schon
verschiedene konstellationen in denen es
ratsam war ein pc
zu machen ist natürlich auch immer noch
ratsam und wird ja zum beispiel auch bei
einigen auslandsreisen auch immer noch
notwendig sein aber wir hatten hier so
verschiedene konstellationen wo auch der
senat oder überhaupt der staat dann sagt
okay dann zahlen wir euch diese wirklich
recht teuren test die kosten hier
inzwischen auch immer noch 50 euro
roundabout ja und das kann kann ja schon
teuer werden wenn man das nicht nur
einmal machen muss sondern vielleicht
auch sogar öfter na also letztendlich
das waren so situation von schülern die
einen positiven selbst test in der
schule erwischt haben ja die dann direkt
zur landeseigenen test stelle geschickt
worden und man durfte eben auch nur
bisher dorthin gehen also wenn man das
auf eigene faust und aus eigener tasche
bezahlt hat dann bei anderen privaten
anbietern dann wurde der auch hier in
der schule bisher nicht anerkannt
genießt es spannend wie das eigentlich
künftig gehen soll es wohl auch noch
völlig unklar alles ja das ist noch in
der schwebe aber wir machen das ja auch
noch nicht so lange so und
einmal kurz ein haken wieso sprichst du
denn eigentlich immer von landeseigenen
test stellen also bei uns in nrw ist das
nicht so bei uns sind das alles private
anbieter ja es sind letztendlich also
ist auch deswegen so weil berlin das
einzige bundesland ist das eben die test
stellen anders organisiert als in nrw
oder in jedem anderen bundesland
letztendlich wir haben hier die
situation dass es natürlich auch
übrigens betrieben wird dann auch von
von privaten anbietern aber hier ist
sozusagen das in einem staatlichen
verfahren geregelt einem staatlichen
vergabeverfahren geregelt wo dann auch
sichergestellt ist dass das eben alles
besonders zertifiziert ist und dass der
staat auch die kosten übernimmt das ist
sozusagen der knackpunkt ja und wie
gesagt das sind eben einfach schüler zum
beispiel oder wir haben die situation
bei einer roten corona wahl erklärte hat
dass wir letzte woche auch schon
thematisiert wenn man so eine meldung
bekommt aufs handy hat man bisher
jedenfalls auch die möglichkeit gehabt
sich auf staatskosten
drei zu testen mit einem pcr test
einfach um die sicherheit zu haben dass
man nicht nicht ansteckend ist das hat
er jetzt nicht notgedrungen was mit
quarantäne zu tun sondern war eben
einfach auch sinnvolle prophylaxe so und
berlin hat es dann ein sehr weg gegangen
die sind dieses sehr formalistisch
verfahren eines vergabeverfahrens
gegangen ja und das ist ja immer mit
fehlern behaftet und bzw ist jedenfalls
sehr fehleranfällig und so möchte es mal
formulieren ja denn wir haben jetzt
vergabeverfahren sind immer ein bisschen
umständlich die müssen europaweit
ausgeschrieben werden dann müssen die
verfahren die kriterien korrekt
abgebildet werden dann gibt es natürlich
auch die möglichkeit für private
anbieter sich da zu melden angebote
abzugeben die müssen natürlich
ordentlich geprüft werden dann gibt es
wieder schwierigkeiten bei der ablehnung
ja auch die muss aber gegründet werden
und so weiter und so fort also berlin
ist den schwerst möglichen weg gegangen
und übrigens auch ein ziemlich teuren
weg kann man mal sagen ja denn das war
eine war ein vergabeverfahren was in
drei losen ausgegeben wurde also drei
einzelaspekte wurden da auf den markt
geworfen quasi als aufgabe die von
privaten anbietern zu erledigen ist und
da hatte man um das jetzt mal überhaupt
auf seine kosten dimension zu geben
hatte man kosten veranschlagt die
wirklich einen ziemlich schwindelig
werden lassen also zum beispiel in einem
dieser ausgeschriebenen lohse so haben
es in dem artikel auch beschrieben
sollte also umfasste 330.000 schnelltest
und 30.000 pcr test im monat und zwar
dafür veranschlagt ende der berliner
senat 22 millionen euro her und wenn man
das jetzt hier mal durch rechnet was wir
juristen ja nur sehr rudimentär kirche
wo du hast es schon gemacht weil das
kann keiner von uns
das hat mein kollege gemacht
ökonomisch und ein cleveres köpfchen und
der kam dann hat mich nicht schlecht
gestaunt als er das mal überschlagen hat
und quasi diese
330.000 schnee test mal abgezogen hat
die kosten ja immer so etwa 18 euro pro
stück wurden mal so an
avisiert in dieser größenordnung und
wenn man quasi die abfahrt kommen für
die pt kommt man für die pcr test auf
sage und schreibe 5 128 euro pro stück
du da würde ich mich auch bewerben als
unternehmen ja also daran eine berater
geben es nicht gemangelt das kann man
mal sagen nur auf der einsamen man muss
eben auch deutlich sagen also das ist
vielleicht auch die tücke dieses
verfahrens ist super und umständlich
dauert lang ist sehr fehleranfällig und
dann ist noch nicht mehr besonders
günstig ja also da kommen ein bisschen
die tränen ins auge so jetzt hat aber
ein unternehmen gewonnen das irgendwie
auch 20 prozent mehr marge eingebaut
hatte schon per se als das günstigste
unternehmen richtet
also das war jetzt ein skurriles
erfahren das ist im vergangenen jahr los
gegangen also rund ein jahr beschäftigt
das schon den berliner senat als wurde
europaweit ausgeschrieben und kamen
mindestens sechs anbieter die da die da
ihre gebote abgegeben haben und das land
ist aber zum beispiel ein unternehmen
dabei hat gesagt wir können das wirklich
wirklich billiger machen ja also haben
dass dann ausgerechnet haben auch schon
erfahrungen damit gemacht und dann sagen
die wand ist ja auch in anderen ländern
schon bild
hatten gesagt wir machen das euch für
die hälfte und dann sagt dieser senat
nein danke wir glauben euch nicht ja es
zu wenig personal für den betrieb der
testzentrum war vorgesehen ja wir haben
hier wir wittern eine finanzielle
unterdeckung die ihm jeden fall
existenzgefährdend für die gebiet haben
gemeinschaft wäre ja es war so
unternehmen das wollte sich mit zwei
anderen unternehmen zusammentun und dann
haben dieses angebot eingebracht in der
sender hat sagt danke aber nein danke so
und inzwischen ja bringst du im jahr
weiter der anbieter sagt na also
übrigens also wir machen das auch noch
woanders amt wir sind noch nicht pleite
gegangen aber das jetzt nur mal hier am
rande wir haben auch noch andere
argumente andere defizite die wir hier
an diesem verfahren rügen und die sind
vor die vergabekammer gezogen gleich
mehrere andere anbieter auch noch die
sind dagegen vorgegangen quasi allem
gegen die vergabe an dieses unternehmen
die dass das jetzt in berlin alles macht
und manager ist schon richtig genau und
jetzt haben wir eben dass das interesse
interessante konstellation also das ist
jetzt so ein verfahren was vor einer
vergabekammer stattfindet ist übrigens
klingt wie gerecht ist aber keins es
eher eine überprüfung behörde die noch
mal guckt ob der senat alles vernünftig
gemacht hat ob es die
den auftrag richtig ausgeschrieben hat
ob die kriterien eingehalten wurden auch
ob das verfahren
ordentlich durchlaufen ist aber die
prüfen das nicht immer sondern das
prüfen die nur auf antrag oder also nur
wer zb eben ein konkurrenzunternehmen
melde und sagt also wir glauben hier
nicht ist das hier vernünftig verlaufen
ist dieses vergabeverfahren
wir hätten den auftrag auch gerne gehabt
überprüft das mal und dann setzt sich
diese lustige vergabekammer daran so war
es in diesem fall jedenfalls ich meine
sogar dass sie auch auf eigenem aus
eigenem antrieb
losziehen können aber hier in diesem
fall war es auf jeden fall so dass die
ihm auf antrag tätig geworden sind und
jetzt in der vergangenen woche zwei
entscheidungen verkündet haben und dem
unterlegenen unternehmen recht gegeben
haben
eigentlich fast jeglicher hinsicht und
zwar amt wurde wurde dem jetzt
bescheinigt dass die aus unzulässigen
gründen aussortiert
wurden und deswegen das ganze verfahren
mit zu wenig anbietern durchgeführt
wurde um es deutlich zu sagen ich habe
in diesem zusammenhang auch mit der
vergaberechtlichen gesprochen das war
ute jasper
von häufchen aus düsseldorf die hatten
mit dem ganzen verfahren nichts zu tun
aber das ist wirklich eine geschlagene
frau auf diesem gebiet und hat schon
viele vergabeverfahren auch erfolgreich
durchgeführt und sie hat eben
klargestellt also das ist schon durchaus
möglich dass es in bestimmten
konstellationen
auch mein angebot abgelehnt werden kann
weil es zu günstig erst näher weil es
weil man sozusagen dann den wettbewerb
auch ruiniert und sich selber so sehr
tatsächlich existenzgefährdend da in den
wettbewerb stürzt dass das nicht gut
gelingen kann man hat ja natürlich als
senat auch das interesse dass der nicht
gleich pleite geht ja sondern dass man
hier eine längere
vertragsverhältnis hat und dass das
ordentlich geprüft wird ordentlich
durchgeführt wird und so weiter und so
fort oder dass das ganze am ende dann
zehnmal so viel kostet wie es eigentlich
in dem angebot stand also ich glaube in
manchen baurechtlichen projekten hätte
man sich wahrscheinlich gefreut wenn die
während das angebot etwas realistisch
oder gewesen wäre als das was dann
nachher die tatsächlich anfallenden
kosten anging und
das war aber hier wohl nicht der fall
also hier hätte man noch wesentlich
besser argumentieren müssen wenn man an
diese schiene verhält es war so wie es
auch ein bisschen absurd also die
vergabekammer hat habe ich verstanden
jetzt in zwei in zwei verfahren
entschieden die vergabe war nicht in
ordnung aber wie geht es denn jetzt
weiter als ich meine dieses unternehmen
betreibt doch jetzt schon alles
feststellen in berlin werden die dann
jetzt alle gestoppt und die dürfen nicht
mehr weiter machen das wäre ein super
timing wo wir jetzt ohnehin so viele pcr
test zur verfügung haben das war
hinreißend aber da ist übrigens auch das
vergaberecht praktischer als sein ruf
kann man mal sagen ja also ist es
natürlich gerade nicht wenn so ein
vertrag dann für unwirksam erklärt wird
und das ganze verfahren neu aufgerollt
wird wie es dann hier passieren muss
also die das vergabeverfahren wird
nochmal jetzt auf los gestellt sozusagen
und dann muss müssen die angebote noch
mal geprüft werden aber das bedeutet
nicht dass bis dahin alles hier brach
liegt und die berliner nicht mehr zum
pcr testen können sondern das läuft so
weiter kann in der zwischenzeit über das
vehikel der direktvergabe hier das ja
seiner rasten
die direktvergabe das ist etwas was
übrigens auch in der korona krise schon
häufiger stattgefunden hat das ist ein
sehr
unkompliziertes sehr schnelles verfahren
da können unternehmen direkt beauftragt
werden das hat zum beispiel auch
gesundheitsministerien sparen gemacht
der frühere
gesundheitsministerien sparen bei dieser
masken bei dieser masken vergaben bei
den masken aufträgen die im knochen und
wirklich viel ärger bereitet haben aber
das ist eben immer genau dieses problem
wenn man will einerseits in solchen
situationen auch ein sehr schnelles
flexibles vehikel haben man braucht man
muss natürlich schnell reagieren können
da hilft die direktvergabe aber da fällt
natürlich diese sehr umfassende prüfung
die direkte die umfassende ausschreibung
das filtern alles erst mal weg also das
kann dann hier auf diesem wege
weiterlaufen und ute jasper eben sagt
auch ganz konkret also sie würde hier
einfach sagen das scheint so viel schief
gelaufen zu sein das wirklich noch mal
von neuem aufzurollen nochmals
sorgfältig zu prüfen
letztendlich auch um das endlich mal auf
rechtssichere beine zu stellen weil das
natürlich schon ein bisschen hanebüchen
was hier alles passiert
ist und ich war übrigens auch erstaunt
wie viel auch in solchen konstellationen
dann den zumindest den anschein von
vetternwirtschaft noch hartner also das
muss man schon relativ deutlich so sagen
es wird einfach sehr ungeniert der
vorwurf erhoben dass hier tatsächlich
ein unternehmen oder das unternehmen
dass hier tatsächlich jetzt die test
stellen betreibt auch auf gutem fuß
steht mit dem berliner senat ist da auch
persönliche verstrickungen gibt man duzt
sich das unternehmen war auch
eingebunden in der formulierung des
ausschreibungstexte also all das sieht
nicht besonders
eines klarzustellen das ist aber nicht
gegenstand des urteils na also dieser
urteile pardon beschlüsse der
vergabekammer das darum geht es da jetzt
nicht sondern das sind sozusagen dinge
die man außerhalb des urteils so hört
richtig ja das ist einfach das ist
sozusagen das was oft was aber quasi
dieser ganzen sagen wir mal so diesen
ganz rechtsstreitigkeiten als fonds
zugrunde liegt und das heißt nicht dass
man das tatsächlich auch beweisen kann
aber natürlich bei diesen ganzen vergabe
dingen spielt das immer noch alleine
haben vielleicht die betroffenen
unternehmen also oder die dann zum zug
bekommen haben dass nicht nur bekommen
weil sie so eine wunderbares angebot
abgegeben haben sondern weil da noch
andere dinge im spiel war also wie ich
war eben sehr überrascht wie deutlich
dass in solchen konstellation immer noch
ein thema ist sagen wir mal so was hat
der berliner senat eigentlich jetzt dazu
nicht also muss man schon auch sagen ja
also wir haben natürlich ordentlich
angefragt und auch mit ordentlich zeit
vorlauf ja also zwei drei tage hatte er
schon zeit und dann kam kurz vor schluss
die ansage dazu können wir uns leider
wegen der fülle der anfragen im moment
nicht äußern ja dann kann es natürlich
dann auch nicht viel sagen dazu
ja noch irgendwie was tun nur die
könnten ja gegen die beschlüsse der
vergabe kann man auch faire wählen also
das muss man sagen es noch nicht
bestandskräftig jetzt geht es übrigens
dann von den vergabekammern kann man
dann vors olg ziehen also dann wird das
ein förmliches verfahren also ein
gerichtsverfahren so wie man es kennt
aber so weit sind wir im moment nicht
vielleicht träumen es ist auch einfach
neu auf und dann werden wir sehen wie es
weitergeht aber das wollten wir hier nur
mal an dieser stelle vielleicht auch zur
ecke zum erkenntnisgewinn nochmal
beitragen
gut nächstes thema
das frankfurter studio ist jetzt mein
kollege reinhard müller gekommen weil
hat schön dass du mal wieder bei faz
einspruch dabei bist was hat uns in
mitgebracht ja hallo corinna freut mich
auch den fall der leider mich nicht
selbst betraf dann ich saß nicht am
steuer aber ein ganz interessanter fall
eines rasers eine schnell vaters der ein
bugatti mit 1500 ps und einer
höchstgeschwindigkeit von deutlich über
400 aber straßen zugelassen auf der a2
bis zum limit gefahren hat und jetzt
stellt sich eben die frage ist
eigentlich in ordnung interessanterweise
hat wohl zuerst auch die polizei die
davon wind bekam weil der herr aus
tschechien das auch ins internet
gestellt hat also sich selbst wäre der
vaart gefilmt hat keine schritte
unternommen was auch durchaus
verständlich ist aber auch verständlich
ist natürlich dass dann eine
riesenaufregung
sprach und die tempolimit diskussion
wieder kam und eben die frage ist das
eigentlich koscher ist das vereinbar mit
unseren straßenverkehrs kommen oder mit
dem strafrecht kann genau weil das ist
ja ehrlich gesagt ganz kurier na also es
geht jetzt so und so eine geschichte die
im netz so hoch geht und heiß diskutiert
wird also man setzt sich in seinen
bugatti und tut eigentlich das was er
offiziell auch darf nämlich so schnell
fahren wie er will nur leider
funktioniert das eben bei ihm über 400
km/h her als es war sind schnell und um
das vielleicht mal deutlich zu sagen er
hat niemanden verletzt es kam zu keinem
unfall sondern es geht einfach nur darum
darf er hier auf derart 2 auf der kein
tempolimit beherrscht so also bis zum
äußersten gehen oder es nicht irgendwann
schluss versagte das strafrecht
eigentlich
genau erstmal ist natürlich interessant
es sind ein paar fahrzeuge zu sehen auf
dem video in der tat die geschwindigkeit
von der mann dachte die bilder auf
teststrecken erreicht erreicht eben auf
einer öffentlichen autobahn und auch
nicht nachts sondern schon früher morgen
ist das
ja und man kann natürlich sagen wir
haben kein tempolimit es gibt eine
richtgeschwindigkeit aber kein
tempolimit es gibt die allgemeine regel
des straßenverkehrs ordnung dass jeder
rücksicht zu nehmen hat aber hier ist ja
auch nichts passiert
strafrechtlich gibt es die gefährdung
des straßenverkehrs das passt aber nicht
recht weil er ja nicht falsch überholt
hat er ist auch nicht hat nicht gewendet
auf der autobahn dahin super
katalogdaten aufgezählt man könnte sagen
so schnell fährt drei viermal so schnell
wie andere an denen er frei ist
teilweise könnte auch gefährlich in den
straßenverkehr eingegriffen haben aber
da wenn man sich anguckt anlagen oder
fahrzeuge zerstört oder beseitigt
hindernisse bereitet das demokrat nicht
oder einen ähnlichen ebenso gefährlichen
eingriff vornimmt und dadurch leib oder
leben eines anderen menschen oder fremde
sachen gefährdet
passt auch nicht so ganz wobei man
natürlich immer
bedenken muss dass der bremsweg
extremist wird ja natürlich würde
kilometer liegen und er ist auch
durchaus wenn sich das anguckt erstmal
so moderat 180 200 auch durchaus über
längere strecken an jahrhundert gefallen
das so moderat sachs bei 200 km/h aber
ja und dann gibt es noch die neue
vorschrift relativ neue vorschrift
verbotene kraftfahrzeug rennen wobei
hier offensichtlich ist dass er kein
rennen gefahren ist jedenfalls ist nicht
ersichtlich dass er mit einem anderen
supersportwagen sich gemessen hat aber
da heißt es am ende eine alternative wer
sich als kraftfahrzeugführer mit nicht
angepasster geschwindigkeit und grob
verkehrswidrig und rücksichtslos
fortbewegt um eine höchstmögliche
geschwindigkeit zu erreichen das könnte
man natürlich an dem andererseits noch
mal ist es nichts passiert ist es per se
grob verkehrswidrig und rücksichtslos
wenn man über 400 fährt wobei sich dann
die frage stellt warum eigentlich 400
wie ist es mit 350 ja was die fenster
genau
und also mir ist nur aufgefallen dass er
auch am anfang interessanterweise gar
nicht als der topspeed fuhr auch so ein
bisschen in der mitte von zwei spuren
gefahren ist was natürlich wiederum
womöglich zeigt entweder ist er
nachlässig war oder seine spuren nicht
halten könnte aber interessant ist schon
der fall war da noch mal diese regelung
zum tempolimit quasi austestet man kann
natürlich sagen wenn er in einem bereich
fährt wo man nicht überschauen kann in
welcher distanz man auch bremsen kann
wäre das jedenfalls war ja auch
jederzeit im fahrzeug rechts auftauchen
kann womöglich rücksichtslos aber es ist
in der tat interessant es gibt eben
stellen wo man auch so schnell fahren
kann das hat der fall bewiesen und es
könnte gut sein dass er davon kommt ja
also letztendlich stößt das strafrecht
das deutsche strafrecht an seine grenzen
interessanterweise ist es das ja aber
widerspricht das so ein bisschen dem
rechtsgefühl aller wie sagt man immer
redlich denkenden bürger und bürgerinnen
wie würdest du das sehen ja ich würde
auch sagen man muss nicht ins
strafgesetzbuch oder in die sonstige
straßberger oder irgendeinen limit
schreiben wenn man denn am tempolimit
festhalle also am fehlenden tempolimit
festhalten will das würde ich auch per
se befürworten aber wenn man jetzt
diesen raser fall der jetzt gerade vom
bgh auch in berlin bestätigt wurde der
ku'damm raser sich ja sogar versuchter
mord weil er eben dhaka ist natürlich
was passiert aber er ist eben mit einer
irren geschwindigkeit für die stadt
verhältnisse durch die innenstadt über
rote am bild gebraucht
da kommt natürlich was zusammen was hier
nicht vorliegt aber wenn die umstände so
sind dass die hohe geschwindigkeit dazu
führt dass man sozusagen vielleicht in
einer langgezogenen kurve oder ähnlich
das nicht mehr einsehen kann und man
muss ja auf der autobahn zwar nicht mit
gegen verbrechen aber mit anderen
verkehr wo man vielleicht auch die frage
stellen kann wie ist das wenn man 400 an
einem vorbei führt der korrekt mann
wegen auf der mittelspur plötzlich
auftaucht weil er rechts ein überholt
wie ist das dann mit dem luftzug etwa
also es können sich aus den umständen
kann sich ergeben dass das die
geschwindigkeit als solcher auch
auswirkungen hat aber in der tat man
kann aber auch die frage stellen ist es
dann muss es ein fall für strafrecht
sein wenn man potenziell gefährlich ist
aber nichts passiert
also diese frage kann man ja mal im raum
stehen lassen und ja vielleicht auch
höhe unserer hörend hörerfragen wie sie
die sache eigentlich sehen da kommt ja
mitunter auch so ganz schön und
kontroversen debatten also vorher frei
wer immer sich dazu äußern möchte auf
einspruch podcast faz.de ist die e mail
adresse wo man uns schreiben kann oder
auch im netz eine diskussion eröffnen
und da unser in auf unserer
internetseite unter dem podcast eintrag
herzlichen dank reinhard müller danken
wir sind auf der a2 unserem dienst
bugatti
so das war also mein kollege reinhard
müller zum thema raserei auf der
autobahn das ja auch mal wieder
beliebter gassenhauern jetzt kommen wir
noch mal zu ein bisschen hörer feedback
ich wie gesagt wir sind entzückt dass es
inzwischen auch so rege angenommen wird
unser aufruf sich doch gerne zu
beteiligen wie gesagt es ist nichts in
stein gemeißelt was wir hier vor uns hin
klappern wir sind immer auch nur
einschätzungen und was heißt ja auch
immer so gerne zwei juristen drei
meinungen und auch die nicht juristen
können sich sehr rege und mit lungen bei
trinkt dazu äußern was tun sie ja auch
sehr rege und mit sehr klugen beiträgen
also wir sind wirklich total fast schon
richtig emotional angefasst weil wir
mittlerweile so viel post bekommen das
ist ganz irre und ganz häufig denke ich
auch mensch ok aspekt noch nie bedacht
irgendwie also bitte bitte weiter so
recht richter co vielleicht deswegen
nummer in aller kürze noch ein bisschen
was was wir jetzt zusammengefegt haben
aus der vergangenen woche da hat sich
tabea gemeldet mit dem thema werbung zum
schwangerschaftsabbruch haben wir
vergangene woche thematisiert und
besprochen ich war da der meinung dass
ich jetzt noch nicht sehe dass ich da
groß viel ändern wird in der praxis der
arztpraxen sich ja dazu zu äußern zu
informieren womöglich gar zu werben sie
sieht das ganz anders und sagt eben die
aktuelle zahl von rund 100000 abbrüchen
pro jahr ist für sie einfach ein
deutliches indiz dass die alltäglichkeit
von abtreibung schon längst da ist ja
also sieben kann sich in der tat auch
durchaus vorstellen
das ist da in zukunft arten von
versteckter werbung gibt das werden wir
dann natürlich auch weiter begleiten und
mal gucken wie sich das dann aus wirkt
also das war jedenfalls durchaus auch
nicht die einzige meinung zu diesem
thema weil die wollte ich immer
beitragen
und dann haben wir auch noch zu unserem
gerichten urteil rückmeldung bekommen
und zwar ging es ja da um die
justiziarin bei der katholischen kirche
die auch schmerz geht haben wollte dafür
dass sie sich mit diesen missbrauchs
fällen beschäftigen musste und da ohne
jegliche betreuung geblieben ist der
arbeitgeber sich quasi nicht gekümmert
hat darum dass es ihr dass sie dabei
hilfe bekommt und da sagt zum beispiel
jeglicher art dass wir genau zu sagen
supervision oder
zehn jahren
und wir fanden die argumentation des
gerichts so ein bisschen merkwürdig dass
die gesagt haben die justiz jahren und
hat eine herausgehobene stelle und
deswegen muss sie sich darum schon
selbst kümmern das fanden wir beide
ungerecht aber rené hat im gericht recht
gegeben hat eben einfach gesagt ganz
ehrlich wer sich auf so eine stelle bei
der katholischen kirche bewirbt und
glaubt da wäre es nur um harmlose
nachbarschaftsstreitigkeiten gehen
offenbar keine naivität die meines
erachtens nicht nicht arbeitsrechtlich
schützenswert ist ja also bei die
missbrauchsskandale in der katholischen
kirche gehen schließlich schon also
lange zeit zurück während schon seit
langen jahren aufgearbeitet und das ist
dann klar dass man sich damit
auseinandersetzen muss ein möbelpacker
kann auch keinen schadensersatz
einfordern wenn er überraschenderweise
und seinen job regelmäßig schwere
gegenstände tragen muss zum beispiel
und jan übrigens mit einem extrem coolen
lebenslauf hat sich auch gemeldet ja
schöne grüße auch an jan hat sich dem
jurastudium auch nach einem
hauptschulabschluss und zwei
ausbildungen gewidmet also gut ab das
offenbart schon wirklich auch viel verve
und der hat sich hier auch zu dem thema
geäußert ähnlich wie rené hat dagegen
gesagt das arbeitsgericht kann er sehr
gut nachvollziehen die argumentation
denn sie hat einen schon herausgehobene
stellung gehabt also er vermutet dass
die leitende angestellte mit
personalverantwortung war die in der
hierarchie ebene relativ weit oben ist
in so einer position die eben auch
entsprechend vergütet wird und mit einem
hohen maß an verantwortung einhergeht
muss man sich eben auch selbst sozusagen
um diese dinge kümmern so das wollten
wir hier nun mal beitragen weil es ja in
der tat auch immer darum geht hier ein
möglichst vielfältiges bild abzubilden
und dann sind wir jetzt aber beim
gerechten otter
was hast uns damit gebracht bier das
gerechte urteil kommt in dieser woche
aus frankfurt und zwar vom
oberlandesgericht und das olg frankfurt
hat einen mietwagen verurteilten 90.000
euro schmerzensgeld und eine kleine
monatliche schmerzensgeld rente an eine
frau zu zahlen die mit einem der
mietwagen des unternehmens einen sehr
schweren unfall erlitten hat jetzt
könnte man danken lang war nicht normal
aber
jetzt wird es gerecht in den agb des
mietwagen unternehmens war nämlich diese
haftung ausgeschlossen
und da hat das olg frankfurt gesagt
leute so nicht also diese dame hatte das
schon sehr lange her im herbst 2010 wie
auch häufiger bei diesem unternehmen ein
auto gemietet und die hatte das dann
immer eine woche lang ist dann irgendwie
von frankfurt nach berlin gefahren so
auf meine geschäftsfrau und hat schon
auf dem hinweg sich bei dem unternehmen
gemeldet haben gesagt leute ich habe
hier probleme ins wurden gang zu
schalten und auf der rückfahrt dann von
berlin nach frankfurt hat sie versucht
das offene fenster hoch zu kurbeln also
zuzumachen dazu die linke hand von
steuer genommen so weit so
nachvollziehbar hat die kontrolle über
das fahrzeug das fahrzeug plötzlich ins
schleudern also ganz schlimmer fall sie
konnte nicht mehr gegenlenken das
fahrzeug ist einfach weiter geschleudert
hat sich so hochgeschaukelt ist nach
links umgekippt und dann über den
fahrbahnrand aus dem gras stück
gerutscht sozusagen und dabei ist der
linke arm von der frau durchs fenster
geraten und wurde abgelenkt und nein
gott ist es sogar ein ganz schlimmer
fall und also auch konnte nicht
repräsentiert werden also eine
superschwere vernetzung und diese frau
hat dann auf zahlung von 120000 euro
geklagt und eben von der schmerzensgeld
rente und auf eine einstandspflicht für
zukünftige schäden im land kriegt hat
sie erst mal verloren beim olg hat sie
jetzt wie ich eben für eine sehr gerecht
überwiegend geworden wie gesagt 90.000
kleine schmerzensgeld rente pro monat
ein sachverständiger hatte nämlich
festgestellt dass dann teile in dem
fahrzeug von anfang an nicht richtig
verbaut worden war das auto sei von
anfang an prinzipiell nicht
verkehrssicher gewesen was und dann hat
sich ja dann hat sich das quasi dass es
dann immer so sukzessive weiter gegangen
hat sich dieses komische ding kreuz
gelenk oder was auch immer das ist
während der gesamten lauf leistung
dieses fahrzeugs halt immer weiter
ausgearbeitet und dann genau während
dieser fahrt der klägerin ist es raus
gesprungen also die konnte nichts machen
es war einfach nicht mehr lenkbar das
auto fertig
ja es ist wirklich ein horror hat das
olg gesagt ist klar das ist ein krasser
mangel der von anfang an da war der auch
den unfall verursacht hat und da kommt
jetzt halt das mietwagenunternehmen
haftet auch für diesen mangel obwohl es
genau das in seinen agb ausschließen
wollte denn in den agb des mietwagens
mietwagen unternehmens stand halt drin
schäden für für leben oder gesundheit an
leben oder gesundheit pardon nur bei
vorsatz oder fahrlässigkeit
ist so eine übliche klauseln erkennt man
es eine ganz normale hwb klausel aber
das olg hat gesagt leute so nicht und
hat gesagt im mietrecht haftet man
grundsätzlich verschuldensunabhängig das
steht nun 5 36 absatz 1 bürgerliches
gesetzbuch liebe jura nerds und diese
verschuldensunabhängige haftung könnte
man zwar grundsätzlich durch allgemeine
geschäftsbedingungen ausschließen aber
nicht wenn der schaden aus einer
verletzung einer sogenannten kardinals
pflicht resultieren also einer
wesentlichen pflicht des vermieters für
die man als mieter des oder als mieterin
des autos ja gerade auch bezahlt und da
sagt ihm das olg also ganz ehrlich bei
einem mietwagen unternehmen ist es halt
eine kardinals pflicht dass man ein
verkehrssicheres fahrzeug vermietet bei
dem insbesondere lenkung und bremsen
funktionsfähig sind ja das möchte man
auch
darum möchte man bitten ja genau und
wenn das mietwagenunternehmen genau
schäden aus solchen verletzungen all
seine absoluten haupt leistungspflichten
für die man ja gerade bezahlt als kundin
oder kunde per agb aufschließen will
dann würde das die mieterin unangemessen
entgegen treu und glauben benachteiligen
pflichten die den typischen
vertragszweck prägen dürfen nicht durch
einen haftungsausschluss ausgehöhlt
werden ilike very much was für das was
für ein gerechtes urteil und echt also
das geht einem zu herzen also herzlichen
dank liebe bier herzlichen dank an sie
liebe hörerinnen und hörer für die
aufmerksamkeit nächste woche bin ich im
urlaub das kann ich schon mal sagen dann
wirst ich habe wieder das vergnügen mit
helene bukowski genau und der dann wirst
du die sendung mit helene bobrowski
schmeißen das wird auch eine große sause
dann wünsche ich noch eine schöne rest
woche und einen tollen rutsch in den
nächsten lassen monat februar
so weit kann ich schon mal sagen danach
kann es nur noch bergauf gehen zumindest
wettertechnisch gewusst hat eine gute
woche da draußen bleibt uns gewogen
[Musik]